welcome welcome everybody it's been a
while since I did a stream a lot to talk
about welcome to everybody a good
evening and a good cob FEV a to all I'm
going to be talking about a lot of
different things tonight it's been super
busy at the David Pakman show not all
good unfortunately but I'll talk about
that a little bit later but I want to
first just jump into something that I
meant to talk about on today's program
and just didn't get to because there was
just so much going on and that's that
this travel ban Donald Trump
accidentally called the travel ban a
travel ban and the big thing was don't
call it a travel ban because we're going
to pretend that it's not a travel ban
and this really goes to sort of the the
spirit of this law or you know failed
law versus the letter of it and all
along you've heard the Trump
administration defend the majority
Muslim country travel ban as not a ban
on a banned targeted at Muslims from
majority Muslim nations and they kept
pointing to the letter of it and courts
actually said the letter of it isn't all
that matters courts said and this is
going to be so major now that there are
numerous tweets where Donald Trump is
calling it a travel ban courts actually
said in deciding that they weren't going
to allow the first two iterations of the
travel ban they said the context in
which the law is passed including past
statements about the intent of the law
actually are valid in terms of thinking
about what it is that the law is going
to do and of course the entire campaign
we're going to call for a complete and
total shutdown on Muslims coming to the
u.s. until we can figure out what the
hell is going on remember that quote etc
etc it matters and as a result I can't
imagine that these tweets are going to
be outside of what courts can consider
in terms of future versions of this
travel ban and I saw I don't remember if
it was CNN or MSNBC today someone
suggesting you know Trump could be
playing that four dimensional chess here
where maybe he's doing this specifically
so that the travel ban will not be
allowed in the future so that he can use
that to then point to how the
establishment is not allowing him to do
what it is that he promised I don't
think so I mean the travel ban at this
point it was a really specific promise
and it's a failure and the Mexican wall
that Mexico was going to pay for it's a
really specific promise and a failure
and he's got to get some successes that
he promised it can't all just be hey I
couldn't do anything because the liberal
establishment and activist judges and
Mexican liberals didn't allow me to I
don't think so I think it's just
cluelessness from Donald Trump and I'm
going to go into that story in more
detail tomorrow and so much news has
broken even since we did today's show
let's just get everybody up to speed if
this is your first live stream on
YouTube with me number one yeah we're
really live right now unless we're not
if it's not 603 p.m. eastern US time on
June 5th 2017 then this isn't live
you're watching a replay but otherwise
it's alive I am here right now talking
to you number two super chat is on you
can use super chat at the bottom of the
chat window where that dollar sign is to
send questions or comments which will be
read and some of them are going to be
great some of them are going to be the
best some of them may not be that good
but that's okay we'll read them and
answer whatever questions come up with
your super chat number three new members
and patrons will get live thank-yous and
shout outs from me during the entirety
of the stream membership is at David
Pakman
slash membership patreon is at
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
unfortunately and I know I always try to
put a positive spin on everything we are
in a situation where we are much more
acutely in need of members and patrons
than we've been for a long time I'm
going to talk about that later
number four obvious trolling and hate
will get you banned subtle trolling will
not there are moderators in the chat I
also have the ability to ban or block
people and I will use it if necessary
because it is free okay so bear that in
mind if the trolling is subtle I
probably wouldn't notice it or the
moderators wouldn't and it probably
wouldn't get you banned so let's dig
into some of the news that's going on
that is going to be on the program
tomorrow number one support for
impeaching the President of the United
States has now exceeded Donald Trump's
approval rating there is a Newsweek
article pointing out that if you compare
two different polls number one you have
the Gallup daily tracking poll which is
if this morning dropped Trump to thirty
six percent approval that's close to his
his presidency low the low is thirty
five percent currently thirty-six margin
of error plus or minus three so
effectively he has tied the lowest
approval of his presidency
compare that to forty three percent of
American voters that support starting
official impeachment proceedings for
Donald Trump more people in the United
States as of today support the
impeachment of the president than the
number that support that approve of the
job that he is doing okay that is that
is major that is major and we're going
to be talking about that on the program
tomorrow extensively Newsweek article
that you can take a look at also
tomorrow on the program and I think that
this is an idea that most of my audience
is going to like although it is going to
be critical of some of the progressive
activist
that is currently going on there is a
major level of engagement among
progressives right now because of the
Trump presidency you are seeing a whole
new the pie has gotten way bigger in
terms of who is engaged and active in
the political system right now and the
resistance meme resisting Donald Trump
and the buffoonery of the Trump
administration is a has been a great way
to get people engaged it's been good for
independent progressive media there's no
doubt about it
but it's not enough and I believe and
there's a New Republic article out by
Eric Sasson which says that the the
Democratic Party right now needs to
stand for progressive policies not just
resisting Donald Trump and what I'm
going to argue tomorrow for you on the
program is that there should there
should really be three or four major
overarching policies that Democrats take
on if they actually want to turn
catalyzed would be the word the activism
that we're seeing right now because of
Donald Trump into action okay and I I do
believe that universal health coverage
should be part of that I'm not
necessarily talking about single-payer
although Medicare for all HR 676 is
something that's out there and we've
talked about it and I believe it's
affordable if you look at my interviews
with UMass economics professor Gerald
Friedman we could afford that you need
to maybe come up with something that
could include that but it could include
other options and this would be
something like a 100 percent health care
coverage that needs to be there I
believe that working on the issue of
corporate power and the influence of
money in politics needs to be there
anyway I'm not going to do the entire
thing now but I think that that this
article in New Republic is spot on and
the the opportunity is the engagement
around resisting Donald Trump but just
resisting Trump is not going to be a
panacea and the reason for that is I've
already outlined why an impeachment of
Trump could backfire significantly on
the progressive cause
and number two I've also pointed out
that if the scenario ends up being Trump
is not impeached doesn't resign but is
riddled in scandal for the next three
and a half years you need to have
something that will work to run on in
2020 and just being anti Trump is not
going to be that okay so I'm going to
talk about that tomorrow I'm also going
to talk tomorrow about Donald Trump's
big announcement that people somehow
cheered I don't get why about
privatizing air traffic control okay up
I'm I don't want to again do the entire
story now but air traffic control is the
agency the government agency that
manages air traffic in the United States
including making sure planes don't crash
into each other and the entire
controversy around air traffic control
for years now has been that ATC is very
outdated and that something needs to be
done to bring them up to speed in terms
of technology now Republicans and I
don't even know if it makes sense to
include Trump in that because this guy's
not a lifelong Republican it's not clear
that many of the people that are in his
his inner circle are Republic lifelong
Republicans either anyway doesn't matter
Republicans like to privatize George W
Bush floated the idea of privatizing
Social Security we've seen a whole bunch
of these ideas the problem with that
there's actually numerous problems with
the idea of privatization of air traffic
control number one is that if and when
you privatize air traffic control you
are setting up a situation where a
commercial aviation will be
significantly a sort of prioritized over
general aviation and although you might
say well David most people are traveling
in commercial airplanes it's not general
aviation by and large that that
is driving the world of aviation and
that's true but the AOPA which is the
aircraft owners and Pilots Association
it's basically a non-profit political
organization that argues in favor of
pilots they are against this and if you
actually read their opposition it's not
just about oh we don't want our pilots
flying Cessnas to not be paid attention
to and to have to pay more because only
commercial aviation is being privatized
you're talking about a lot of safety
features when you're talking about IFR
flight plans versus VFR flight plans and
the costs associated and so many of
these other things again I'm going to go
into detail tomorrow there are a number
of reasons that are not just about your
uncle and his Cessna not wanting to pay
more that are that are significantly
against the privatization of ATC the
other issue is that privatizing would
likely not solve the issue of delays
that airlines like United have very
loudly blamed the ATC for and this is
this is something that has been a really
popular sort of scapegoat for major
airlines other than Delta Delta actually
came out against privatization of ATC
but a number of airlines are in favor of
privatizing air traffic control they are
using ATC as a scapegoat and you can
google that United has done this
extensively they are saying hey the
reason why we're so delayed all the time
it's because of air traffic control and
while there's a grain of truth to that
it's not really representative of the
non weather delays that most air path
air traffic passengers experience so
this is the this is just something that
doesn't make sense and this is part of
Trump's infrastructure week which is
really just a bogus attempt to distract
from scandal after scandal that Trump
has been having so we'll dig into ATC
privatization tomorrow might seem like a
boring topic but it's actually really
relevant because it relates to so many
of the issues with the Republican party
platform at large one of which is
private
of functions that are not really well
served by privatization Trump trying to
circumvent that by saying well it will
be a nonprofit organization that
replaces ATC but it's still riddled with
problems we're also going to be talking
tomorrow about how the Donald Trump
administration put out a press release
actually referencing or linking an
Infowars article which is of course the
propaganda conspiracy website of Alex
Jones we're going to be dealing with
that on the show tomorrow
that bizarre NATO speech that President
Trump gave in Brussels last week it
appears as though that was not actually
some kind of well-crafted and
coordinated plan that everybody in the
Trump administration was on board with
we've now learned that the Trump
national security team was completely
blindsided by Donald Trump's speech at
NATO and all of the the absurdities that
he said so we're going to be dealing
with that tomorrow and and a lot of
other important stories and and we'll
also be previewing the James Comey
testimony which is scheduled to happen
on Thursday I don't want to talk about
that now because I'm going to talk about
that more a little bit later okay so
let's put a pause on that and deal with
some super chats first and foremost
floppy kid has just sent a ten Canadian
dollar super chat Trump very explicitly
and churlish Lee may be childishly
started mentioning Sadiq Khan's name in
his tweet do you think because it sounds
other as opposed to just Mayor of London
which he used in his initial tweets
there is no doubt that Donald Trump is
using London Mayor Sadiq Khan's name in
his tweets because he wants to reference
that Sadiq Khan is Muslim absolutely no
question about that
and and we did a story today about the
London attacks and actually Saudi Arabia
and you might be saying well they don't
like it the London attacks in Saudi
Arabia what's connected there there's
actually a lot a lot to discuss there
and I did so I encourage you to watch
that but yet there's no accident in
Trump using Sadiq
named in his tweets Robin loose sent a
five euro super chat asking David when I
see an ad do I need to watch it till the
end you don't need to do anything you
don't want Robin but if the question is
do we earn more if you watch the entire
ad I don't have a specific answer to
that my instinct is yeah if you watch
the entire ad we're probably earning
more than if you don't but I don't know
what the difference is I genuinely don't
don't know Frank macwrite Frank macwrite
sent the twenty dollar super chat can
you talk about Wonder Capital I'm
assuming you've done research about this
company but do you also invest with them
first time investing and asking based on
your suggestion so yeah we brought on a
wonder capital as a trial advertiser
they did a one day run last week I
believe it was and they're going to do a
one day run this week and Wonder Capital
allows you to invest in in solar energy
projects I so III don't know that it's
the that I want to earn a get too much
into you know like the potential
earnings or anything like that related
to Wonder capital here because you do
have to be what's called an accredited
investor to invest with Wonder Capital
and even though you can invest as little
as $1,000 you do have to meet those
requirements of being an accredited
investor and just in the interest of not
saying anything that may not be 100%
appropriate given that there are
regulations around these types of things
I would encourage you to read about it
on their website it's pretty extensive
and you you can take a look at that
there Frank okay so listen I try to put
a positive spin on everything all the
time but unfortunately there's a pretty
negative situation that's impacting the
show right now and it's been more than a
month since I've talked about this and
many people may not even know about this
I mean we're gaining 300 or so three to
four hundred YouTube subscribers per day
meaning that if you've only been
watching for the last month there's
probably about 12,000 people that have
no idea about
I'm about to discuss and we we are at a
sort of existential crisis for the David
Pakman show and it all relates to the
YouTube advertiser boycott which the New
York Times wrote specifically about how
it's influencing our YouTube channel
back in mid-april in an article by
Amanda Hess called how YouTube's
shifting algorithms hurt independent
media so listen I'll give you the real
quick summary of what's going on a
couple articles were published in
corporate media one in The Wall Street
Journal
basically taking screenshots of
YouTube's racist YouTube videos with ads
playing on them like ads for coke okay
the policy of YouTube is if you have
overtly offensive hateful or racist
content ads shouldn't play there and by
and large the problem on YouTube is not
that that algorithm was too relaxed
despite what the Wall Street Journal
article would want you to think it's
actually that the algorithm was too
strict we cover stories about terrorism
war whatever and even though we're not
advocating for violence or showing gory
images or whatever most of those clips
when we do them get marked as not ad
safe and they don't run any ads so the
problem has been the ad algorithm is too
strict YouTube after advertisers
panicked when they saw those articles
and said we're going to pull our money
out of YouTube YouTube said we're going
to flip a switch on a new ad algorithm
that determines when ads play before our
videos and that destroyed our channel
overnight now when I say destroyed I
don't mean like oh
we took a 10% hit we lost ninety-nine
point something percent of our ad
revenue overnight okay
throughout April we saw it Evan flow it
came back a little bit one day about 15%
then it was down back to 5% whatever the
case may be but we were crushed I mean
YouTube I've been totally upfront about
this makes up nearly half of our revenue
right and what we experienced as a
result is a question about whether we're
going to be able to continue the David
Pakman show
we immediately started pushing
membership and patreon
and we had an initial push of people who
recognized the urgency but I can't talk
about patreon and membership all day
right we've got a show to do people are
here for the content so since May 3rd
mums been the word I've not mentioned a
word about what's going on sort of
hoping that people would keep coming in
as new members and patrons and that some
of the YouTube ad revenue would come
back unfortunately and again I'm
supposed to always put a positive spin
on everything that goes on it's not a
positive situation the urgency has waned
understandably because I haven't been
talking about what's going on
and unfortunately the revenue has not
recovered beyond where it was on May 3rd
which is about a third we've got about a
third of the revenue on YouTube that we
used to have we're getting about 2/3 of
the ads that we used to get we used to
get ads on 60% of our videos now we're
getting ads on 40% of our videos and
those ads are paying about half as much
because they are significantly lower
quality ads there are fewer advertisers
on YouTube YouTube uses a bidding system
so the more advertisers that want to buy
ads the more those ads pay because there
are fewer advertisers they pay less so
2/3 times 1/2 leaves us with 1/3 our
YouTube channel is earning about 1/3 of
what it was before
that's a problem that's a problem and
you know my commitment has been not to
make changes to the programming of the
show I don't want to have to do that as
a result of the fact that provocative
material won't be monetized at all that
on average we're making 1/3 of what we
were making before and the way to that
is if we continue to get a viewer
support and and there's basically two
ways to do that and I've talked about
them before and I'll mention them you
know real quick here
number one is membership ok and if you
go to david pakman.com slash membership
this has been the number one funding
source for our show for a very very long
time and on the second page of the sign
up which you can see here there is a
field which is coupon code if you look
at the normal rates which I think are
quite reasonable 6 bucks a month
sixty-four the year we produce you know
25 or so hours of content every single
month plus a members-only bonus show i
think the normal rates are reasonable
but that's still a lot of money for many
people six dollars a month or 60 for the
year if you want a 40% discount by all
means if that's what it takes to get you
involved please feel free to use the
coupon code you see on screen which is I
voted 17 okay and along those lines I
want to send a big thank you to Maria
Reed who has signed up today through our
membership page I want to send a big
thank you to Janet Mansfield who just
what we've been chatting on the
livestream has signed up as well as to
karla butler thank you thank you to all
and I'll keep doing shoutouts and
thank-yous the other thing that's
available and this is just super simple
if you don't want to deal with
membership and stuff on our website and
the bonus show or whatever and if you
just want to pledge a dollar or two
right and every single dollar or two
really helps you can go to
patreon.com/scishow and as little as a
dollar a month makes a difference and it
it really does replace a lot of that
missing YouTube revenue and if you can
just do a dollar and please don't think
that because you can only do a dollar
it's not worth doing it if only 10% okay
that not 90% not half not a quarter if
one out of every 10 YouTube subscribers
on our channel committed to just $1 a
month not only do we make up for the
lost revenue we destroy it and we become
independent in a completely new way
which would be absolutely fantastic so
along those lines
Lucas has just pledged $2 at patreon.com
slash david pakman show I'd love to get
back up to 1500 patrons and you know
there's been some confusion because
people see you know David on the 31st of
May you had fifteen hundred and forty
patrons and now you're down to 1486 what
happened the first of the month so when
you make a pledge on patreon you're
pledging that amount
immediately and then those pledges recur
monthly on the first of the month and
inevitably some people's credit cards
expire during the month and so what
happens on the first of the following
month is a bunch of people's pledges
fail and we are knocked back down beyond
the 1,500 patron mark so that's where we
are and we need we need your support I
wish I could say hey we've recovered the
lost revenue it's now been April May
it's been about nine weeks since the
YouTube ad boycott started and we've
recovered about a third of the revenue
but unfortunately that that's just not
not not enough and we do need your
support okay let's get to some of these
super chats here let's see what we've
got I know that I've missed a couple
clarf one two three four has sent a five
Australian dollar super chat saying how
to beat ad pocalypse do more amazing
long four pieces and interview a bunch
of internet ideologues to leech their
viewers and Spanish content okay I mean
we're continuing to do the long-form
pieces in fact we have a great long-form
piece about political correctness coming
up a couple weeks from now we finish the
research on it narration has been mostly
done and it's going to be a really
really good piece and anybody who knows
where I stand on the issue of political
correctness is probably going to find
something in the video that they like
and something in the video that they
dislike so that's coming up interview
internet ideologues to leech their
viewers that only works if they have
more viewers than we do and a lot of the
people that others want me to debate or
create feuds with actually have far
lower traffic than we do and here's the
now without mentioning anyone
specifically here's what I want to tell
you if you really want to compare the
size of a YouTube channel to another
don't go to the channel and look at the
number of subscribers go to
socialblade.com compare the two channels
using the tool that they have there
and look at views per month because you
can have 2 million subscribers but if
people aren't watching your videos it's
not really worth that much is it so
please before you you start emailing me
by the way the trolls who say you will
never have as big a channel as X Y or Z
I then will say that's interesting I
didn't know their channel was so big
I'll go to social blade and we've got 5
6 or even 10 times the monthly views of
some of these other channels it's weird
very very odd ok gr has sent a 15 dollar
super chat hey pac---- DZ take it easy
hi in trees like he progressively
excessively blessed with rationality
please tell me DZ how crooked do you see
that cushion er policy from son-in-law
to prodigy love gr I have a really hard
time figuring out what on earth gr is
talking about I think he may have had a
few too many shots of coffe Fe tonight
and maybe is not completely coherent
there but I appreciate I appreciate the
super chat and feel free to keep them
coming and if there are questions there
that I can understand I will absolutely
answer them ok a few other stories that
are lower on my list whoa sorry as I hit
my microphone that might have been loud
for you and I apologize for that
few other stories on my list that I want
to talk about hopefully tomorrow ok the
James Comey testimony James call me
fired FBI director is going to be
testifying on Thursday this is major for
a number of reasons number one when's
the last time you saw this much
anticipation for testimony of this kind
from a former FBI director or any type
of official so number one people are
paying attention to what's going on in
government and that's a very very good
thing we were unsure up until today
about whether exerting executive
privilege would be used by the White
House to block James Comey from
testifying now why would the White House
be able to use executive privilege to
prevent James Comey from testifying
answer is very simple
James comb
is going to be testifying about
conversations that he had with Donald
Trump and as a result because that's
what's going to be discussed Donald
Trump could have used executive
privilege to prevent James Comey from
testifying today we heard from deputy
press secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders a
vile human being and I'm not talking
I want to be super clear here because
that people have already started to tell
me David
when you criticize Sarah Huckabee
Sanders it seems like you're criticizing
her because of her physical appearance
no you might be inferring that I find
Sarah Huckabee Sanders and the way in
which she is seemingly completely at
ease distorting and lying in a
despicable way about just known facts in
front of the press corps I find that to
be absolutely vile and if you think it
has to do with her physical appearance
that's more about your impression of her
than mine
Sarah Huckabee Sanders was asked today
by the press corps will executive
privilege be asserted in order to
prevent Michael Flynn from testifying
and she said no the White House is not
going to do that and Michael Flynn will
testify I think Trump is does is not
thrilled with the reality that Michael
Flynn is going to be testifying but even
for Trump who doesn't seem to give two
shits about optics when it comes to
anything related to Russia I think
somebody got to him rightly so and said
it would look really bad if you prevent
Michael James Comey from testifying and
what I predict is that in the next 48 to
72 hours before the testimony of James
Comey you will start to see big Lee big
league I guess I should say in this case
you will see big league attempts on
Twitter from Trump to start both
pre-empting the James Comey testimony
and maybe some false pseudo scandal
something along the lines of Cobb feffy
but less funny to distract from what
James Comey is going to say and then as
and after James Comey testifies there
will be a concerted effort to discredit
him as a disgruntled former whatever
partisan hack
blah blah blah and that that's what I
think is going to happen and you know I
actually have been reading and I have no
idea you know how it is where there's a
tempt I know that that this might come
as a shock but sometimes media outlets
will attempt to blow up some future
testimony when nothing is really going
to happen but I've been starting to see
some articles saying Admiral Mike Rogers
on Wednesday is going to have some
bombshell claims and I don't know I
don't know what the deal is with that
but we may learn more about that so
those are my thoughts on James Comey I
will be watching with bated breath
because it is endlessly fascinating what
is going on there
let's get to a couple more super chats
here Victor Savelle has sent a $20 super
chat sign up and be a david pakman show
member also another good plugin is tube
buddy on Chrome it will show all kinds
of analytics all right well thank you
very much Getty Germany has sent it to
Euro super chat saying simply cob feffy
cob feffy yeah I'm actually I'm in talks
for cob Febby to be providing the
Wardrobe for the David Pakman show going
forward it's kind of a unique and and
sort of quirky designer and I think
you're really really going to like their
stuff it's pretty androgynous clothing
but soon David Pakman show a tire will
be brought to you by cob feffy Frank
macwrite cent to $20 super Chad no major
legislation passed looks like the focus
is not on jobs at all failed travel ban
failed health care reform lots of
tweeting and golf
this seems damaging to the Republican
Party what do you predict happening you
know at this point by the way there's a
poll about this at david pakman.com
which is is trump Teflon will anything
stick to him or can he golf 23 times in
19 weeks the way we reported on him
doing
day and just avoid negative
repercussions I mean on the one hand
it's not hugely positive for Trump as
evidenced by the his approval rating
right at the beginning of the stream I
pointed out that 36% of Americans
approve of the job that Donald Trump is
doing and 43% of Americans want the
president impeached it's not good when
more people want you impeached than the
number that approve of the job you are
doing so on on one hand there are
repercussions but will Republicans be
able to sort of figure out a way to
navigate what's going on with Trump to
avoid it personally hurting them in the
2018 midterms and the answer is quite
possibly the answer is quite possibly
and I mean at this point when you see
like a Paul Ryan press conference he
shows up and the guy acts like it's a
completely normal situation at the White
House and he talks about really much
seemingly mundane legislation and on the
one hand it seems totally out of touch
with reality because it's scandal after
scandal but at the same time it's sort
of smart because then Paul Ryan can say
I'm focused on the issues you know
whatever drama is going on in the White
House I am focused on the issues and
Republicans may well be able to avoid
being brought down by the sinking ship
of Trump if indeed Trump's ship sinks
let's go to Monica Malina who is doing a
partial Spanish message which is a
popular thing interests in Super chats
these days saludos the California mingun
de tu programa which means greetings
from California I love your show hope
you get all the independent funding you
need keep up the good work
Thank You Monica and on that note let me
say a few more thank you so on the
patreon front and again we are trying to
make up for significant lost revenue
from the YouTube ad pocalypse ad boycott
and patreon is one of the ways we are
doing that Luke Wittig has just pledged
$2 a month
Thank You Kirk Ryan has just pledged $25
per month
thank you so much Kirk very generous
Stephanie Walsh has pledged $2.00 per
month and soul mama has pledged $10 per
month thank you very much I really
really do appreciate that every one of
those pledges makes up for many lost
YouTube dollars in revenue at david
pakman.com slash membership the coupon
code
I voted 17 is available which gives you
a 40 40 percent discount off of
membership and I want to say big league
Cobb feffy style thank yous to Kristina
McKenna Delphine Tay and John Blass
kovitch all three of whom signed up
while we've just been chatting here
during the live stream thank you thank
you very very much
and by the way still on the table I just
wanted I don't know if people care about
this but a few weeks ago I put up on
Instagram at David Pakman by the way
follow me on Instagram if you don't
David Pakman I put up this picture on
Instagram which is just a picture of
what happens to my hair if I don't go to
great lengths to deal with it as I like
to say after I shower I have committed
to doing an entire show in our studio
with my hair like this if and when if
and when we get to 2,000 patreon
supporters and again we started the
livestream today with 1486 we are now
beyond that thanks to the of just Bigley
contributions of people while we've been
chatting here and if we get to 2,000 I
will do a show with my hair like that
for better or worse I don't know what
will happen
Isiah Roe has sent a $30 super Chad
Isaiah who by the way I need to sing
Isaiah's praises because not only is
Isaiah a major super chat contributor
during the live streams Isaiah actually
called into the show last week and got
on the air and we were we chatted with
Isaiah which was great to hear from him
so oh and by the way the
week we normally take calls Wednesdays
we're taking calls tomorrow to account
for we're off on to the Friday show
everything's been shifted up by a day so
tomorrow Tuesday June 6th at 1:15 p.m.
Eastern u.s. time we'll be taking phone
calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 if you want
to calling that all being said let's get
to Isaiah's super chat what do you think
of solutions like Xtreme vetting travel
restrictions surveillance of mosques and
radical Imams prosecution of human
smugglers sanctions on Saudi Arabia etc
in response to terrorism okay there's a
lot here and it's not all the same so
first of all extreme vetting we've been
doing extreme vetting the vetting that
we're doing is no different than what
was done under President Obama in order
to get asylum or refugee status
confirmed if you're coming from a
variety of countries around the world
we're already doing extreme betting and
it's funny that what Donald Trump is
talking about doing is something Obama
was doing even though Obama was doing a
terrible job travel restrictions we've
talked extensively about ways in which
travel restrictions could or could not
actually improve the terrorism or
potential terrorist situation recall
that when you looked at the travel ban
countries some of the main sources of
terror around the world over the last 20
years were not on that list and many of
the countries that were on the list have
not actually exported terror to the
United States and as a result I think
that if you want to talk about travel
restrictions you first need to say hey
we're going to get outside of the insane
depraved alliance with Saudi Arabia for
example and we're not going to take
countries off the list on principle
that's number one and then you can have
a discussion about whether that type of
policy would or wouldn't make sense of
course the way that Donald Trump has
done it twice is not even constitutional
surveillance of mosques and radical
Imams okay so this now starts to get
into slightly different considerations
bulk surveillance the way that at
word Snowden exposed we know has not
really been effective James clapper
you'll remember those hearings under
during the Obama administration James
clapper initially sort of making this
blanket statement that oh we've
disrupted dozens of plots as a result of
that however then when he was asked to
provide instances he said you know
actually it's not that clear that that
program has disrupted that many read any
plots so if you're going to be doing
bulk surveillance I think that that's a
pretty difficult cell the surveillance
of radical Imams I don't think we need
to limit it to radical Imams we have
systems in place where there if there
are reasons to suspect that an
individual may be radicalized we have a
full system in place FISA coords
Warren's all sorts of stuff and that's
something that law enforcement has and
can continue to do and it's targeted and
it's when there are specific reasons to
suspect that not someone may be a
catalyst for radical activity a
prosecution of human smugglers yet those
are crimes and and you've got to
prosecute that sanctions on Saudi Arabia
before listen before we get the
sanctions on Saudi Arabia we've got to
stop selling them hundreds of billions
of dollars in weapons so we're pretty
far from that and by the way please
check out my video today
that I did based on the London attacks
which went live about two hours ago on
our youtube channel and that video is
about Saudi Arabia and it's titled
London terror we need to talk about
Saudi Arabia
all right so please check that out so
those are a few thoughts
Isaiah gr has sent a fifteen dollar
super Chad P DS you know how I play
shootin on that cff a hearing Pakman
rhymin is a great way of passing time
especially about that Trump nasty crappy
state of mind for easy easy how crooked
Kushner bee Kushner be crooked
all right gr Kushner be crooked for sure
no doubt about that
to ATZ turbo has sent a $5 Super chat
saying Republican lieutenant governor
Calley is trying to make Michigan a part
Legislature would this get regular
people involved or become a lobbyist
dream I am less interested in the
part-time legislature at angle than I am
in the term limit angle and I've talked
about that in a couple of different ways
and I think that the term limit angle
you know there's enough what would you
call them uh typically lawyers and
business people who are sort of like the
typical people that end up making it
into politics there are enough of them
we're just putting in term limits is not
going to make it so all of a sudden
schoolteachers and scientists are
filling the halls of Congress and state
legislatures but it would help it would
help and I think that a part time I'm
less um I'm less moved by but I think
that it's interesting and there are a
number of states that have part-time
legislators and legislative sessions
that don't run the entire year by the
way not that our members of Congress in
Washington DC are working working that
that much either right they've got a lot
of vacation as well gr has sent a
five-dollar super chat
I will sponsor a couple memberships if
some folks can't afford them DZ happy to
chip in a little more pack slammer yeah
bad mamma-jamma
love gr I don't know what kind of
substances result in these types of
messages but I am flattered that anybody
would want to sponsor memberships we've
got memberships currently that a sponsor
sponsored the best thing gr would be if
you email in and the way we would do it
is how would we do it I guess I would
announce that we have X number of
memberships available as gift
memberships we would come up with some
kind of way to give them out and then
once the people when somebody has won or
we've assigned those memberships you
could create them under someone else's
name and email address and input your
payment information all right so very
generous gr appreciate that would
absolutely love to do that on that note
let me say thank you to a few more
new David Pakman show members of course
we outlined earlier the major major
problem that we're having right now with
funding for the show as a result of the
YouTube advertiser boycott and as a
result it is quite literally more
important than ever that we continue to
grow our membership base and on that
note you can get a 40% discount off of
membership by using the coupon code
I voted 17 and a few new members
literally just in the last eight to ten
minutes while we've been talking here
that have signed up Jason Pritchett
Jason Pritchett has signed up thank you
Jason
you're a great American to quote Sean
Hannity although honestly I don't know
if you're American
doesn't matter folks of all
nationalities equally valued as viewers
as well as as members of the David
Pakman show Oh bill Carlson bill Carlson
has joined up at david pakman.com slash
membership using the coupon code I voted
17 bill saving himself 40% as a result
of using that coupon code also big thank
you to mark grinn mark Guin has signed
up at david pakman.com slash membership
one of the best member benefits that
people like is when you remember you get
access to the bonus show every single
day we've got the public broadcast show
which you see on youtube split up into
different clips that start publishing
usually at 4:30 p.m. Eastern Time but
there is an entire other show if you are
not a member you don't know about this
it's called the bonus show every single
day we do an other show it is an
additional program this is not the
broadcast show it's an extra show called
the bonus show just for our paid
subscribers it's more casual we talk
about science stories we talk about more
world politics we talk about all sorts
of stuff people love it it's it's
absolutely the best tremendous bonus
show of all bonus shows that I've ever
seen that's for sure and that's a
benefit you get at david pakman.com
slash membership when you sign up and if
it's all too
involved and you don't care about that
you like watching on YouTube and you
just want to send us a dollar or two a
month you can go to patreon.com/scishow
we are working on getting up to 1500
patrons there okay super chats they keep
coming in Sonny Torres has sent a $10
super chat are the attacks in Europe
indicative of the dangers of immigration
from primarily Muslim countries or am I
missing something
okay well I mean so there's no simple
answer to that question there is no
doubt that when you have immigration
from a country with culture a to a
country with culture B and those
cultures can have aspects that are
seemingly
at odds with each other you're going to
have problems now specifically when it
comes to the attacks in Europe which
have been by and large perpetrated by
extremist Muslims there's no doubt that
the radicalization is the problem
there's no rule that says hey you've got
Muslim immigration and you immediately
have terror attacks there's no rule
about that but as I talked about in the
video that went live at 4:30 p.m.
Eastern Time today when you have a
country like Saudi Arabia which adheres
to one of the most extreme versions of
Islam which is this Wahhabist seventh
century Islam that leads to the public
beheadings and subjugation of women and
gays and people who kiss at a beach that
you see in Saudi Arabia when you have
them funding mosques in Western
countries yeah that's part of the
problem that is absolutely part of the
problem there's absolutely no way around
it and that's something that's going to
have to be dealt with getti Germany has
sent a five dollar super chat I'm sorry
five euro super chat Jakob FIFA do cope
FIFA's El Cap Ferrat
nosotros cope the famous issue scope
effing so basically this is like a full
conjugation of two cab Fifi as a verb
um I hope that was worth five five euro
for you victor Savelle has sent a five
dollar super chat have you thought about
merchandising as an extra source of
revenue i Sport a say fancy deep Hisle
shirt Viktor there are numerous shirts
available and in fact if you go to david
pakman.com slash gear you will see that
there is the original david pakman show
logo t-shirt
there is the david pakman show
established in 2005 seal design t-shirt
and there is the hatred mail design
t-shirt and when I say t-shirt there is
a men's and women's style t-shirt but
you can also get all three of those
designs as a zip up hoodies and you can
also get them as fitted women's style
zip up so there's those are available a
Victor no reason to wait and by the way
if you want a david pakman show
bumper-sticker those are available at
david pakman.com slash gear if you want
david pakman show coffee and not cob
feffy just regular coffee we have two
coffee blends available at david
pakman.com slash gear we now have
several dozen viewers who are regularly
just getting their coffee from us I mean
like clockwork once a week once every
two weeks once a month depending on how
much coffee they're drinking we are
getting orders from the same couple
dozen people and it's been a really
really great thing the coffee okay Ian
Camarillo sent a $5 super chat will you
clear up the misunderstandings with a
che Goodman live or in a recorded video
I don't think that there are any more I
mean I don't have anything to clear up
we did a video about the Seth riche
conspiracy theory it was a nine and a
half minute video about a minute and a
half was about some of the different
people that were brought on to this arti
panel to talk about it and we talked
about AJ Goodman he responded by saying
that I was lying and untrustworthy and
dishonest
the next day I did a video basically
just pointing out where I had gotten my
ideas about a che Goodman and while
certainly I was speaking off the top of
my head in that video and there was not
a literal match between what I said in
the initial video and what he
specifically said the gist of everything
I said was completely defensible and
since then I actually have not seen in
full anything but I know he did a whole
string of videos attacking me and there
have been other youtubers attacking me
and you know what I'm too busy producing
a nationally syndicated show with 200
radio and TV stations to even watch the
hours of videos that have been generated
by that and I think what I go back to is
I'm doing my show we've done 40 stories
since this H a Goodman thing it's not a
big part of my life so to speak and the
fact that you know ten people are making
videos about me and I'm just doing my
show I think tells us a lot sort of
about the dynamics there and I'm not
finding myself needing to do any more
about about a che Goodman but clearly
the if you want to see videos about H a
good minute about me what I'm told is
that there's tons of them floating
around YouTube although I haven't seen
more than 15 seconds of any of them gr
cent the $5 super chat fancy planning
from the feat finance savvy Pakman I
like it I will email you posthaste love
GR your biggest fan in the history of
time no matter what alright thank you
very much Jennifer karein has sent the
$20 super chat I like the idea of
sponsoring one or two memberships
speaking of memberships don't forget to
don't forget to mention the that there
are subscription levels I discovered the
different levels and was able to
increase the amount I paid yeah the base
level for membership is six dollars a
month and sixty dollars for the year and
you can say 40% off of that with the
coupon code I voted seventeen but there
are memberships at the monthly level
that go up to 48 dollars
month and memberships at the yearly
paradigm that go up to four hundred and
eighty dollars a year and I am very
proud to say and flattered by the way
that we have members at every single
membership level we have people how
flattered how flattering is it that we
have people who pay forty eight dollars
a month for our program month in and
month out they could pay nothing because
we'd still be doing the show the whole
point of the show is that it'd be
available to everyone regardless of
ability to pay
we have people who pay forty eight
dollars a month for our show you can pay
three dollars and sixty cents a month if
you want by selecting the six dollar a
month plan and using coupon code I voted
seventeen we have people who pay four
hundred and eighty dollars a year as
members for the show you don't have to
do that you can pay thirty six dollars
for the year by selecting the $60 a year
membership and using the coupon code
I voted seventeen so yes thanks Jennifer
if you want to sponsor a couple
memberships like G are proposed by all
means just email in will come up with a
little contest we had actually we did
one a little while back where we limited
the free memberships I think I had five
three or five of donated memberships we
limited it to a high school or college
student who was a fan of the show and
all they had to do was put together a
short not really an essay just like a
two or three paragraph thing about why
the David Pakman show matters to them we
read then selected winners and then they
were given sponsored memberships by
other people so feel free to email in
Jennifer and gr and we can get that all
set up two-dollar super chat from gr
everyone knows it's packed D Z Victor I
think a response to Victor who did a
super chat where he apparently tried to
also Institute some new nickname for me
Getty Germany sticking with the cop
feffy theme a2 euro super chat it was
totally copped FA ed abscess I don't
know how far we're going to go with this
one guys but but it seems to be going
pretty far
and then a $2.00 a to British pound
super chat from Hobbiton is the Trump
administration a tragedy or a farce it
is both
it is both Hobbit and no doubt about it
and Victor Savelle with a $2 super chat
responding to gr deep Hisle for life yo
so a lot of action just a lot a lot of
action going on there and I know that
the super chats are used as a goof a lot
but they are actually they actually are
a great thing because they are a direct
way to support the show and I appreciate
everybody who is sent in a super chat
and on that note I'm going to go make
dinner thanks to everybody who has
signed up for membership thanks to
everybody who has also signed up at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
please get those dollar contributions in
they do make a difference they do make a
difference if just one out of every ten
of you makes a patreon contribution this
funding issue will be over instantly
talk to you tomorrow